now governments across europe are
stepping up the fight against the delta
variant of the coronavirus
health authorities hope to see one step
ahead or stay one step ahead of
rising infections by increasing
vaccinating rates
france is focusing in particular on
health workers and may make
immunization compulsory but not everyone
agrees
this is the way to go
joseline has had her hands full during
the pandemic
helping some of the most vulnerable at
this retirement home southeast of paris
to protect them the assistant nurse has
been wearing masks
and gloves but there is one precaution
she'd rather not
take at least not for now
i want to wait a bit longer before i get
immunized
we need to know more about these new
vaccines first
after all the government got a lot of
things wrong at the beginning of the
pandemic
so i don't want to rush into this
precipitation
like her almost half of france's nursing
staff have not yet been immunized
but forcing them to would be unfair says
jocelyn
first we were the pandemics heroes and
now we're the black sheep because we
prefer to wait before getting the
vaccine
that makes me so angry
jocelyn's manager agrees she says such a
rule would cause major problems for the
nursing home
they should try to convince people
instead of forcing them
we're already struggling to find
personnel and several of our highly
qualified staff
have said that if they have to get the
vaccine they'd rather quit their jobs
but this virologist thinks that if
france is going to prevent the next
covet 19 way from overwhelming hospitals
vaccination will be crucial and that
includes health workers
the vaccine gives 95 protection against
severe symptoms
we need to get 80 or 90 of the
population immunized
especially with the delta variant
which results in an infected person
infecting up to eight
others that's a huge
number
so far just over one third of the french
population
is fully vaccinated and the number of
first jabs per day
has been falling over recent weeks but
the government knows that
time is of the essence that's why it has
been ramping up its campaign
to push people to get vaccinated in the
media
through posters and with temporary
vaccination centers like this one just
outside paris
city hall here you can get a cobit 19
jab
without having to book a slot in advance
making healthcare workers get vaccinated
might help the country approach
the crucial vaccination threshold but
reaching it
remains an uphill struggle
let's take a look at some other
developments in the pandemic
israel is offering a booster shot of the
biotech pfizer vaccine to adults with
weak
immune systems scientists now say it's
possible to catch two virus variants at
the same time
a ninety-year-old woman from belgium is
believed to have died from strains
first identified in the uk and south
africa
and british authorities are warning
against large gatherings before the euro
2020 football final